and right now at noon we are your local  election headquarters and it is official  sheriff joe lombardo is seeking the  republican nomination for governor  glad to be with you here at noon i'm  david charns lombardo kicking off his  campaign at rancho high school where he  graduated more than three decades ago  he is calling himself a lifelong  republican and conservative leader  today i'm standing here to announce my  candidacy for governor  because if we don't put an end to the  single party rule  eroding our state of the values laws and  opportunities to make nevada great  we won't have a lot left to fight for  and we'll have more on what this all  means and what we  what he told me about former president  trump coming up this afternoon at 4 00.